This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。你有意愿为真正的改变出一份力吗？LaCite学院为你提供“依赖与老年学”项目。获取相关的能力，
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
这些能力对于陪伴和支持面临健康与依赖问题的人至关重要。开启一段丰富的职业生涯，为全国各地的法语社区服务。如果你具备法语能力，
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
这一切在City皆有可能。今天就访问Collage L.A.C吧。这是加拿大卫生部支持的全国卫生培训财团的一项倡议。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
它们变黑了。这把我吓死了。邪恶，醒醒吧。我是那个看到克里瓦克和德皮波实施谋杀的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得无动于衷。
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
我说，我没有罪。我将把这个秘密带进坟墓。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Bone Valley》中的《魔鬼采石场》。快乐至关重要，它也同样难以捉摸，但现在有一个令人兴奋的新方法来开启你的旅程，
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
走向更加充满喜悦的生活。Joy 101。这是一个由我——霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的直播聊天。打开免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
搜索Joy 101并立即收听。由CVS呈现的霍达·科特比主持的Joy 101。每个人都把我当作一名足球运动员，但在此之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，从我出生起，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情感共存。这不是一个普通的播客。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着意味着什么进行的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·奇查里奥·奥南德斯，
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was. Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. And these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets.
请在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Learning to Be Human》。你的丈夫并非你想象的那样。你的身体也并非你所想的那样。你的身份由一段秘密的历史塑造。我是丹妮·夏皮罗。这些只是我将在《家族秘密》第14季中探索的众多惊人故事中的几个。
He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off. And that was the last time I saw him. Listen to Season 14 of Family Secrets. secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
他有点把我推开说，让开。然后他走出了前门，跳上一辆车开走了。那是我最后一次见到他。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《家族秘密》第14季。大家好。我是珍玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一个我们探讨二十岁时最大的改变、时刻和过渡期，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。
It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the of our 20s. Today, I have another bonus episode for you. If you are new to this series, our bonus episodes are our smaller, bite-sized episodes that seek to break down and debunk certain famous psychology theories or pseudoscientific ideas. You may see a lot online or hear everybody from your mom to your best friend, to the guy on the train talking about. Basically, this series is, It's myth busters, but for psychology and in podcast form. We've done the truth about dopamine, we've done personality tests, narcissism, flow states, whether the frontal lobe actually develops at 25.
非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们在这里剖析二十岁的点点滴滴。今天，我为你准备了另一期特别节目。如果你是这个系列的新听众，我们的特别节目是更小、更精炼的短小精悍的节目，旨在剖析和揭穿某些著名的心理学理论或伪科学观点。你可能在网上看到很多，或者听到从你妈妈到你最好朋友，再到火车上的路人都在谈论这些。基本上，这个系列就是：它是心理学界的流言终结者，但形式是播客。我们已经探讨过多巴胺的真相、性格测试、自恋、心流状态，以及前额叶皮层是否真的在25岁发育成熟。
And today, we are doing Maslow's hierarchy of needs and why our understanding of it is nowhere near where it needs to be. And also why the modern day depiction of Maslow's hierarchy is actually, incredibly inaccurate, maybe even false. It's a huge episode. I'm not going to waste any more time talking about things that aren't Maslow's hierarchy of needs. Let's jump straight into it. If you have a psychology background, even casually, if you have dabbled in the self-help space, I think it's safe to assume you have come across the hierarchy of needs. And the hierarchy of needs, Maslow's hierarchy of needs, was formed from his like major work that he's,
而今天，我们要探讨的是马斯洛的需求层次理论，以及为什么我们对它的理解远没有达到应有的水平。还有为什么现代对马斯洛需求层次的描绘实际上极其不准确，甚至可能是错误的。这是一个很大的主题。我不再浪费时间去谈论那些与马斯洛需求层次理论无关的事情了。让我们直接切入正题。如果你有心理学背景，哪怕只是略懂一二，如果你涉足过自助领域，我想可以肯定地说，你一定遇到过需求层次理论。而需求层次理论，即马斯洛的需求层次理论，源于他发表的一项重大著作，那就是人类动机理论。即使你不知道我说的名字是什么，你也一定见过它的图片。你在职业顾问的办公室里、在科学教科s书上、在Instagram上都见过它的图片。它通常被表现为一个有五层的金字塔，建立在一个简单的理念之上：在你能够专注于成为最完整的自己之前，你需要满足最基本的人类需求，这些需求位于金字塔的底部。然后你再一步步往上爬。这个理论是由亚伯拉罕·马斯洛提出的。他是一位美国心理学家，在20世纪40年代首次提出了这个概念。马斯洛以实践一种被称为人道主义心理学的心理学流派而闻名，该流派优先考虑推动人类繁荣和自我实现。
published, which was a theory of human motivation. Even if you don't know what I'm talking about by name, you have seen an image of this. You have seen an image of this in your career counselor's office, in a science textbook, on Instagram. It's usually represented as a pyramid with five layers, and it's built on a simple idea. Before you can focus on becoming your fullest self, you need to satisfy the most fundamental human needs, which sit at the base of the pyramid. And then you work your way up. Now, this theory was developed by Abraham Maslow. He's an American psychologist, and he first kind of put this together in the 1940s. Maslow famously practiced a form of psychology called humanistic psychology, which prioritizes the push towards human flourishing and self-realization.
而这个层次结构可以说是这个特定心理学学科的基石，因为它表明，金字塔底部的需求虽然看起来很基础，但对于生存至关重要。而且它们也没有受到心理学家足够的审视。它基本上是在指示学术界、心理学界：如果你希望，如果你希望你的患者，如果你希望全人类都能蓬勃发展并获得成就感，我们需要更多地关注诸如情感安全、财务安全、纯粹的身体安全、拥有食物、拥有水之类的事情。他基本上，他用自己想出的这个理论来描述他在心理学和人类身上看到的很多事情和很多问题，比如为了在社会中实现更大的心理和智力繁荣而需要解决贫困问题；为什么在我们摆脱生存状态之前，我们无法发挥创造力或回答关于生命的深刻问题；以及为什么情感安全性与身体安全或财务安全同等重要。而且他还，我不认为这是他的本意，但现在它在很大程度上被用来解释成为最好的自己的途径。如果你在这个阶段无法想象出那个金字塔，我强烈建议你在谷歌上快速搜索一下它长什么样，因为带着这个视觉画面，这期节目会更容易理解。不过，让我带你从最底部开始，逐层了解每一层。因此，在马斯洛金字塔的底部是我们的生理需求：食物、水、睡眠、住所，这是让我们活下去的基本要素。这些是我们人类生存的核心
And this hierarchy is like the cornerstone of this specific psychological discipline, because it suggests that needs at the bottom of the pyramid, whilst seemingly basic, are essential for survival. And they're also not examined enough by psychologists. And it basically instructed the academic, the psychological community, like if you want to, if you want your patience, if you want humanity to thrive and to be fulfilled, we need to pay more attention to things like emotional security, financial security, just physical. security, having food, having water. And he basically, he used this theory that he came up with to describe a lot of things and a lot of problems he saw in psychology and with humanity, like the need to address poverty in order to achieve greater psychological and intellectual thriving in
需求。一旦我们拥有了这些，理论上我们就可以建立我们的安全需求。安全需求是下一层。它本质上是说，一旦生存问题得到解决，我们就可以开始考虑长期安全和身体安全。我们可以开始考虑我们的长期健康和我们的日常规律，并知道明天不会完全充满不确定性。第三层是爱与归属感。人类是社会性动物。所以我们需要友谊，我们需要家庭。
society, why we can't be creative or answer deep questions about life until we're out of a place of survival and why emotional security matters just as much as physical safety or financial security and he also, I don't think this was his intention, but it's now very much used to explain how the pathway to becoming your best self. If you cannot picture the pyramid at this stage, I would highly recommend, do a quick Google search of what it looks like because this episode will make a lot more sense with that visual in mind. But let me walk you through each layer starting from the very bottom. So at the base of Maslow's pyramid are our physiological needs. food, water, sleep, shelter, basic things required to keep us alive. These are our core human survival
我们需要亲密关系、社区。我们需要有意义的关系。我们需要感到与他人有联系并被他们接纳。但在此之前，你无法优先考虑这些，你知道的，直到你知道你的下一顿饭在哪里，或者直到你感到安全为止。所以爱与归属感是第三层。在那一层之上是尊重的需求。这包括自尊、自信、成就、认可，本质上就是这种核心信念和核心意识，即我们很重要，我们是有价值的。这其实只关于我们如何看待自己，以及我们觉得别人是如何看待我们的。你此时大概可以
needs. Once we have those, the theory goes that we can then build our safety needs. Safety needs is the next layer. It is essentially saying once survival is taking care of, we can begin to think about long-term security and physical safety. We can begin to think about our long-term health and about our routines, kind of knowing that tomorrow isn't going to be completely uncertain. The third level is love and belonging. Humans are social creatures. So we need friendship. We need family.
看出所有这些需求是如何一层层叠加在一起的，直到最后我们到达金字塔的顶端——自我实现。正如我之前所说，显然。这是实现我们潜能、追求我们的目标、在创意和智力上表达自己、作为个体成长，并成为我们有能力成为的人的渴望。有趣的是，在晚年，马斯洛实际上用“自我超越”取代了“自我实现”，将其作为人类的最高目标。我说“取代”其实不对。他基本上增加了一个额外的层次，而那个额外的层次或水平就是自我超越。对他来说，自我实现相当个人主义，随着年龄的增长，他开始对人们如何解读它产生异议。
We need intimacy, community. We need meaningful relationships. We need to feel connected to other people and accepted by them. But that cannot be prioritized until, you know, you know where your next meal is going to come from or until you feel safe. So love and belonging is the third. layer. And then on top of that layer is esteem needs. This includes self-respect, confidence, achievement, recognition, essentially just this core belief in this core sense that we matter and we have value. It's really just about how we see ourselves and how we feel we're being perceived. You can kind of
最终，他意识到，能够对他人善良，我们对利他主义、同理心的能力，能够将我们的好运传递下去，做一个好的社区成员，这才是人类体验的顶峰，而不是感到自己很有成就，也不是觉得你了解你自己。马斯洛非常喜欢用两个词来描述这一点，它们可能是这个播客里我将要说出的最难的两个词。我们准备好了吗？第一个是Gemen，哦天哪，我再试一次。好的。再来一次。Gemen Shaftend get full。我可能把它说得一塌糊涂，但这是一个德语词。它的意思是关心他人所带来的心理健康。下一个词是菩萨（bodhisattva）。
see at this stage how all these needs build on each other until finally we get to the top of the pyramid, which is self-actualization. As I said, I think previous, obviously. This is the desire to fulfill our potential, to pursue our purpose, to express ourselves creatively, intellectually, to grow as individuals, and to become who we are capable of becoming. Interestingly, later in life, Maslow actually replaced self-actualization with self-transcendence as the highest human goal. I said replaced, that's not true. He basically added an additional layer and that additional layer or level was self-transcendence. Self-actualization to him was rather individualistic and he kind of took issue with how people were interpreting it the older that he got.
这是一个佛教概念，认为一个获得圆满的人是一个努力对他人怀有同情心的人。如果我读错了，请见谅。我总是无法驾驭复杂的词汇。我的澳大利亚口音让做任何超出残酷而简单的英语之外的事情都变得无比困难。但这种自我超越、菩萨（我甚至不去尝试那个德语词了）的想法，是教科书所不包含的。
Ultimately, he realized that being able to be kind to others, our capacity for altruism, for empathy to take our good fortune and pass it on, being a good community member, that is the peak of the human experience, not feeling accomplished, not feeling like you know yourself. There's two words that Maslow loved to use to describe this, and they are probably two of the hardest words I will ever say on this podcast. Are we ready? The first is Gemen, oh God, I'm going to try again. Okay. One more time. Gemen Shaftend get full. Probably butchered it, but it's a German word. it means the psychological health that follows from caring about others. And the next word is bodhisattva.
我以前在学心理学的时候，从未见过有人谈论这个。本质上，我一直在反复强调这一点，因为我觉得，我觉得这一点太重要了。去实现自我实现固然很好。但你拿它来做什么呢？就像，如果你没有与其他人建立联系，你真的能作为一个孤独地待在象牙塔里、成就斐然的个人而获得真正的满足吗？如果你对他人没有那种促使你与他们建立联系、向他们付出并对他们友善的同理心，在马斯洛看来，这才是最开明的心理状态。所以，这是人们对马斯洛需求层次理论不知晓的一个方面。其实还有一个特殊的奖励层，我们还需要实现的另一件事。另一
It's a Buddhist notion that somebody who is fulfilled is somebody who strives for compassion towards others. Apologies if I got those wrong. I can never get my way around complex words. My Australian accent makes it so hard to ever do anything that is not just like brutal, simple English. But this idea of self-transent, of bodhisattva, of I'm not even going to try the German one, is something that textbooks
个我们经常弄错的事情是，请敲响鼓点，马斯洛实际上从未将他的需求层次展示或阐述为一个金字塔。他甚至很少称其为层次结构。根据心理学家斯科特·巴里·考夫曼（Scott Barry Kaufman）的说法，他实际上接手了马斯洛未发表的著作，并以拓展这些理论为己任：我们所如此熟悉的这个金字塔形象，实际上是由管理顾问们创造的，他们试图兜售对该模型的某种特定诠释。考夫曼认为，这种描绘实际上对马斯洛最初的理论造成了巨大的损害。它真的把它过度简化了。英国心理学会的一篇文章谈到，金字塔的描绘暗示了我们走向自我实现、
don't include. I've never seen this spoken about, at least when I was studying psychology. Essentially, and I'm really drilling this point home because I think, I just think it's such an important point. It's all fine and great to self-actualize. But what do you even do with that? Like, can you truly be fulfilled as an accomplished individual alone in your ivory tower if you are not connected to other people. And if you do not have empathy for other people that drives you to connect with them and give on to them and be kind to them, that to Maslow was the most enlightened psychological state. So that's one thing people don't know about Maslow's hierarchy of needs. There is actually another special bonus layer, another thing we need to achieve. The other
自我超越的旅程几乎就像在打电子游戏。这容易让人产生一种假设：你通过打开一扇门，从一层升级到下一层，再到下一层，来在生活中升级。马斯洛的概念是，每一组需求——你的社会需求、你的尊重需求、你的生存需求——都是相互依存的，它们必须同时被体验。这个层次结构需要以一种整合的方式来看待。也就是说，每一组需求都是相互支撑的，不是连续的，而是循环的。这种金字塔描绘没有很好解释的另一件事是，人们怎么可能处于
thing we often get wrong is that, drum world, please, Maslow actually never displayed or articulated his hierarchy as a pyramid. He very rarely even referred to it as a hierarchy. According to the psychologist Scott Barry Kaufman, who actually took on Maslow's unpublished work and made it his mission to expand upon these theories, this pyramid depiction that we are so familiar with was actually created by management consultants who were trying to sell a particular interpretation of the model. This depiction, Kaufman argues actually, he says it's done a great disservice to Maslow's original theory. It's really simplified it. In an article by the British Psychological Society, they speak about how the pyramid depiction suggests that our journey towards self-actualization,
不同的阶段，而它前面的每一个阶段并没有完全100%得到满足。例如，那些不觉得自己在社交上有很大支持、可能真的很孤独、没有与家庭甚至社区建立联系的人，仍然可以继续创作出惊人的艺术作品，照顾他人，达到自我实现和自我超越的顶峰，尽管从外表上看他们的社交需求似乎并未得到满足，你知道吗？那些可能没有足够食物吃、正在与贫困作斗争的人，仍然能体验到深刻的意义，仍然对自己保持尊重。你大概能看出，这种金字塔的想法在这一点上变得非常棘手，因为它把更高、更有目的性的功能仅仅留给那些富有、健康、快乐和被爱的人。我们知道事实并非如此。马斯洛也不希望我们认为事实就是如此，即你只有在生活一切顺利的情况下，才能达到这个崇高的顶点。并且，如果你是那种没有遭受痛苦、过去没有遭受痛苦、拥有所有可用需求的人。我认为我对马斯洛需求层次理论的一个巨大质疑，再次在于它会将某些，你知道的，更高的——再次申明，我说了更高，但是，你知道的，某些看似更开明的功能形式——把它们把关起来，只留给那些拥有一切或生活本来就一帆风顺的人。如果你正在经历贫困，
self-transcendence operates almost like a video game. And it kind of leads people to assume that you level up in life by unlocking the door from one layer, to the next, to the next, to the next. Maslow's conceptualization was that each cluster of needs, your social needs, your esteem needs, your survival needs are interdependent, and they have to be experienced simultaneously. The hierarchy, it needs to be viewed in an integrated way. That is, each cluster of needs rests upon each other, not in a consecutive way, but in like a circular way. The other thing this pyramid depiction doesn't explain well is how people can be at
如果你很孤独，好吧，你还没有达到那个层级。所以你绝无可能实现自我实现。当我们其实知道事实并非如此时，你绝无可能在自我超越的同时照顾他人。好吧，我们其实不是“大概”知道。就像我们确实知道一样。所以这是关于马斯洛需求层次的另一个谬论或误解，即它根本不是一个金字塔，他认为它更具循环性。现在让我们转向下一个误解，关于马斯洛理论的下一个被隐瞒的历史部分，也许是所有这些里面报道最少的一个。马斯洛其实并不是这个人类繁荣理论的最初创造者。他甚至不是第二个，他甚至不是第三个。他只是给它起了一个名字。他只是，他只是。
different stages without every single stage before it being entirely 100% fulfilled. For example, people who don't necessarily feel like they have great social support, who are maybe really lonely, aren't connected to a family unit or even to a community, can still go on and make amazing art and care for others and reach those peaks of self-actualization and self-transcendence, even though their social needs from the outside don't seem to be being met, you know? People who may not have enough food to eat, who are struggling with poverty, still experience deep meaning, still have respect for themselves. You can kind of see how this pyramid idea gets really tricky in that it gate keeps
只是那个把它推广开来的人。马斯洛的需求层次实际上受到了黑足民族（Blackfoot Nation）人民的启发。在一个美洲原住民部落，我想他们位于蒙大拿州，他们也在加拿大。所以在20世纪30年代，30年代中期，马斯洛去了这个叫做Sikseka的地方。它是黑足民族最大的保留地，他在那里生活了六个月，观察他们的社会等级制度。他算是学会了他们的语言。更具体地说，他了解了一种生活方式，这种生活方式没有一个英语单词，过去没有，现在也没有。但当我们把它与马斯洛的理论进行比较时，它们看起来非常相似。他被自己所看到的深深启发了。
higher, more purposeful functioning for only the rich, healthy, the happy, the loved. And we know that's not the case. And Maslow didn't want us to think that that was the case, that you can only achieve this high, high point if everything is going right in your life. And if, like, you are a certain type of individual who does not suffer, has not suffered, has all their needs available to them. I think that's a big issue I take with Maslow's hierarchy is, again, that it can gatekeep certain, you know, higher. Again, I said higher, but, you know, certain seemingly more enlightened forms of functioning for people who have it all together or who have had life handed to them in a way that was already all together. And if you're experiencing poverty,
根据阿尔伯塔大学提供的信息，黑足民族的模型实际上构成了马斯洛最终理论的倒置。对他们来说，基础是自我实现。在他们的观点中，我们每个人作为神圣的火花来到这个世界，身上内嵌着一个更伟大的目标。在我们出生后，归属感随之产生，因为部落在那里爱护和照顾我们。正是通过这种爱，我们才获得了基本的生存需求和基本的生存资源。你知道，那是我们获得食物的方式。
if you're lonely, well, you haven't achieved that layer. So there's no possible way that you can be self-actualized. There's no possible way that you can self-transend and care for others when we kind of know that's not true. Well, we don't kind of know. Like we do know. So that's another kind of myth or misconception about Maslow's hierarchy, the very fact that it is not a pyramid, he thought of it as more circular. Let's now turn to the next misconception, the next hidden part of history to do with Maslow's theory, and perhaps the least reported of them all. Maslow was in fact not the original creator of this theory of human flourishing. He wasn't even the second, he wasn't even the third. He just gave it a name. He was. He was.
那是我们获得安全感的方式。那是我们获得保障的方式。那是我们照顾这些需求的方式。然后，从这一切中，我们实现了社区实现、自我超越或社区超越。因为由于这个系统，我们能够支持每个人，人们回馈社区。这带来了一些更伟大的东西，甚至不在马斯洛的模型中，但仍然如此至关重要，那就是被称为文化永续性（cultural perpetuity）的东西。
was just the person who made it popular. Maslow's hierarchy was actually inspired by the people of the Blackfoot Nation. In a Native American tribe, I think they're in Montana, they're in Canada. So in the 1930s, mid-1930s, Maslow went to this place called Sikseka. It's like the largest reserve of the Blackfoot Nation, and he spent six months living there, observing their social hierarchy. He kind of learned their language. More specifically, he learnt about a way of life they had, which doesn't have an English word, didn't have one then, doesn't have one now. But when we compare it to Maslow's theory, it looks very similar. He was deeply inspired by what he saw.
部落的每个成员，他们说，总有一天会离去？所以传递知识以及关于社区如何运作以及人们如何互相关照的深刻真理。为了保持和谐，那是最终的目标。以便社区、家庭、文化、社会能够延续。我不知道。当我最初学习这个的时候，我从未学过这些。我觉得这真是，没能被包含在内让人感到挺遗憾的，因为我认为，
According to information from the University of Alberta, the Blackfoot model actually was structured as the inverse to Maslow's eventual theory. So for them, the base was self-actualization. In their view, we are each born into the world as a spark of divinity, with a greater purpose embedded in us. After we're born, belonging occurs as like the tribe is there to love and care for us. And through that love is how we then receive basic survival needs and basic survival resources. You know, it's how we get food.
我甚至觉得他们的理论比马斯洛的好一点。对我来说它更有道理。所以我将更深入地探讨这部分历史是如何被埋没在历史书中的。所以马斯洛最初来到Sikseka是为了探索一个不同的理论，那是他的社会统治理论以及社会如何通过暴力、惩罚、羞辱等不同手段来维持秩序的理论。但相反，正如蒙大拿大学编制的他的日记和记录所显示的，他某种程度上只是，他发现了一些他没想到自己会看到的东西。他发现了惊人的合作水平、极小的倾斜、恢复性正义、饱腹感、高水平的。正如他们所说，生活满意度，他估计80%到90%的黑足部落成员拥有自尊质量，
It's how we get safety. It's how we get security. It's how we tend to those needs. We then from all that achieve community actualization or self-transcendence or community transcendence. Because due to this system, we're able to support everybody. people contribute back to the community. And that leads to something bigger that isn't even in Maslow's model, but is still so crucial, which is something called cultural perpetuity.
这种自尊质量在他的（西方）人口中只有5%到10%的人才拥有。就在那时，他想出了这个想法。看这些人拥有什么，看他们能取得什么成就。这些人正在实现自我实现，因为所有这些需求都是在社区内并通过社区得到照顾的。他在那里时，还目睹了一场赠予仪式（giveaway ceremony），据说这激发了他的自我超越理念。在赠予仪式期间，这是Sikseka的一项盛大仪式。部落成员将他们的圆锥形帐篷排成一个圆圈，并公开堆放了他们过去一年收集的所有东西。拥有最多财产的人（你知道的）讲述了他们是如何找到这些财产的，他们是如何积累这些财产的，他们是如何
Each member of the tribe, they say, is one day going to be gone? So passing on knowledge and passing on a deep truth about how the community operates and how people take care of each other. And in order to maintain harmony, that is the ultimate goal. so that the community, the family, the culture, the society endures. I don't know. I never learned that when I was, I never learned anything about that when I was studying this originally. And I feel like it is such a, it's quite sad that that's not included because I think,
制作它们的。然后他们把最后一点东西都送给了更需要的人。对马斯洛来说，那就是自我超越。这个社区已经达到了这样一个地步：如果社区正在受苦，如果社区有需求，个人物品、个人东西就不再重要了，个人财产有什么意义呢？我认为这是这期节目中最重要的事情，因为据我们所知，马斯洛本人并不羞于谈论这一点。据我所看到的记录显示，我认为他非常坦诚，这正是这个想法的来源。它确实启发了他。但据研究人员称，美国和加拿大政府掩盖了马斯洛理论的黑足根源，因为他们不想抬高关于这些人的积极叙事。直到马斯洛去世后，它才真正被重新发现，与其说是重新发现，不如说是被重新宣传。大约50年后，当有人去写一本关于他生平的书时，他们去了史密森尼档案馆，然后去了马斯洛的女儿那里，女儿基本上允许他们发掘他隐藏的档案箱。当他们翻看它时，他们在那里找到了他在那里的所有条目、所有记录以及所有早期的理论构想，这些构想在七年后成为了他的《人类动机理论》，也就是我们现在所知的需求层次理论的发源地。了解这一点并分享这一点非常重要，特别
I think almost their theory is a little bit better than Maslow's. It kind of makes more sense to me. So I'll go into this a little bit further about how this kind of came to be buried in the history books. So Maslow originally arrived in Sikika to explore a different theory, and that was his theory of social dominance and how order is maintained in society through different means like violence, punishment, shame. But instead, as his diaries and records, which were produced by the University of Montana show, he kind of just, he discovered something he didn't think he was going to see. He discovered astounding levels of cooperation, minimal inequality, restorative justice, full bellies, high levels of. of life satisfaction, as they say, he estimated that 80 to 90% of the Blackwood tribe had a quality
是考虑到心理学作为一个日益严重的、但同时也是历史上以白人为中心的西方化学科，有着如此多的潜在问题。在这里，我们有一个核心概念、核心理论的例子，一个千百万人所了解的理论，它直接借鉴并基于美洲原住民团体的教义和文化和谐。然而，他们并没有因此获得赞誉。只有那个给它起名字的人得到了。几年前，我实际上第一次知道了这一点，这要归从于该播客的一位听众。从那以后，它就一直留在我心中。所以我真的很高兴我们今天能谈论它。而且，（你知道的）为这个主题做一个完整的节目，时机再合适不过了。
of self-esteem that was only found in 5 to 10% of his population. And that's when he came up with this idea. Like, look at what these people have and look at what they can achieve. These people are self-actualizing because all of these needs are being taken care of with and through the community. He also witnessed a giveaway ceremony while he was. was there that is said to have inspired his idea of self-transcendence. So during the giveaway, this is like a big ceremony in Sikika. Members of the tribe arranged their teepees in a circle, and they publicly piled up all that they had collected over the past year. And those with the most possessions, you know, told stories of how they found them, how they amassed them, how they
带着这种心态，我真的、真的鼓励大家去更多地了解这一点。在蒙大拿大学网站、阿尔伯塔大学网站上有很多非常有趣的、可获取的历史记录，上面记录了他所有的日记等等。而且当时也有很多亲历者的个人记录，就在他写这个理论的时候在场的人，是的，深入挖掘这些真的非常有趣。但带着这一点，让我们转向马斯洛所谓层次结构的最后一个神话，那就是它是普遍适用的，或者更进一步说，它有强大的经验证据使其成为一个可靠且有效的框架。事实是，马斯洛的需求层次并没有
made them. And then they gave every last thing away to people who needed it more. And to Maslow, that was self-transcendence. This community had reached a point, where personal artefacts, personal things didn't matter anymore if the community was suffering, if the community was in need, what is the point of personal possessions? I think this is the most important thing in this episode, because Baslow himself, as far as we know, did not shy away from speaking about this. He was, I think according to records from what I've seen very open, that like this is where the idea came from. It really inspired him. But according to researchers, the American and the Canadian government buried the black
得到那么多的科学支持，尽管它真的、真的很受欢迎。我想在谈完他从哪里得到这个理论之后，在最后把这一点包括进来，因为这表明他想出、窃取、获得启发——无论你想怎么称呼它——的方法并不是科学的，即使它们产生了一些引起我们很多人共鸣的东西。它完全源于他自己的个人观察、个人轶事以及特定人群的知识。而且他从未在适当的科学环境中测试过它，一次也没有。他所有的这些想法，你知道的，我们有这五个需求，并且现在变成了六个，我们需要完成所有这些需求才能实现其他目标，
foot roots of Maslow's theory because they didn't want it to elevate a positive narrative about these people. It was only really rediscovered, not so much rediscovered, but republicized after Maslow died. Some 50 years later, when someone went to write a book on his life and they went to the Smithsonian archives and then they went to Maslow's daughter who essentially gave them permission to excavate his hidden archival box. And as they were looking through it, they found all these entries and all these accounts and all these early theoretical ideas from his time there that would become his theory of human motivation seven years later, which is the birthplace of the now we know as the hierarchy of needs. This is so important to know and to share especially,
自我实现和自我超越对每个人都是可接近的，甚至人们从中获得某种感觉或体验，甚至是具有影响力的，这些都没有被检验，没有被真正调查过。自他去世以来，研究人员几乎没有发现支持五需求层次有效性的证据。其中一个最常被引用的评论来自1976年的布里奇沃和瓦巴（Bridgewell and Waba）。他们回顾了基于他的理论的研究，并指出：
especially since psychology has so many underlying issues as an increasingly but also historically white westernized discipline. Here we have an example of a core concept, a core theory, one that millions of people know about, that was directly informed and based on the teachings and cultural harmony of a Native American group. And it's a theory they don't get credit for. Only the man who named it does. I found out about this a few years ago, actually, for the first time, thanks to a listener of the podcast. And it's just kind of stuck with me ever since. So I'm really glad that we get to talk about it today. And it's, you know, perfect timing to do a full episode on this.
文献回顾表明，马斯洛关于人类动机的需求层次理论几乎没有得到现有研究结果的明确或一致的支持。马斯洛的一些主张被完全拒绝，而另一些则充其量得到了混合的、可疑的支持，对于一个在几十年里一直在学校、心理学实验室、教室和办公室里被教授的理论来说，这是一个令人疯狂的说法。但事实就是这样。它甚至可能都不是真的。现在，为他辩护一下，马斯洛从未宣传他的理论是关于人类繁荣的最终真理。他老实说只是在写作、推测，他对这个感兴趣，然后有些东西就固定下来了。但有趣的是，他从黑足民族那里汲取的那些原始理论和
with that in mind, and I would really, really encourage you to go and look at this more. There's a bunch of, a bunch of like really interesting historical accounts available at like the University of Montana website, University of Alberta website that goes through all of his diaries and all of that. And there's also a lot of just like personal accounts from back then of people who were there when he was writing the theory that, yeah, it's just really interesting to, to dig into. But with that in mind, let's move on to the final myth of Maslow's so-called hierarchy. and that is that it is universally applicable, or even further, that it has strong empirical evidence that makes it a reliable and valid framework. The truth is, Maslow's hierarchy is not
最初的想法，在现代社会中被断章取义了多少。我仍然认为这是一个很好的想法。我仍然认为它确实为我们如何为人们提供支持、社会应该而且可以如何运作以及我们应该如何照顾他人提供了一个承诺或道路。但它配得上作为心理学中最著名的理论之一的地位吗？我不知道。在下面让我知道你的想法。这就是我今天为大家准备的全部内容。正如我所说，这是一期特别节目。我总是做这些特别节目，结果最后讲了30、40分钟，但这并不是它们的初衷。我们正试图让这些节目简短而甜蜜。所以告诉我你们的想法。让我知道你是否认为外面有一个更好的理论，比
that scientifically supported, even if it is really, really popular. And I wanted to include this at the very end after talking about where he got the theory from, because it shows that his methods of coming up with stealing, getting inspired by whatever you want to call it, were not scientific, even if they produced something that a lot of us relate to. It was entirely derived from his own personal observations and personal anecdotes and the knowledge of a specific people. And he never tested it, not once in a proper scientific setting. All of his ideas that, you know, we have these five needs and five needs only now six, that we need to complete them all in order to fulfill others,
马斯洛的更好。让我知道你是否对这期节目中了解到的任何事情感到惊讶，或者你是否有我可能漏掉的关于这的更多背景或信息。正如我所说，实际上我并不了解很多这方面的内容，直到几年前一位听众联系我，纠正了我在一期节目中所说的话。我对此非常感激，因为它把我带上了这条非常有趣的道路，让我学到了这么多。所以如果你还有什么想补充的，我很乐意在Spotify下方的评论区听取你的意见，或者如果你在其他地方收听，可以在Instagram上私信我：That Psychology Podcast。另外提醒一下，我们现在在Netflix上了。如果你想看《你二十岁的心理学》的完整节目，不过不是这期节目，因为我们的
that self-actualization and self-transcendence is accessible to everybody and that people even get a sense or a feeling from it, that it's even impactful, not examined, not really investigated. Since his death, researchers have found little to no evidence for the validity of the five-need hierarchy. One of the most frequently cited reviews came from Bridgewall and Waba in 1976. They reviewed studies based on his theory and stated,
特别节目只留给收听音频播客的人，也就是我所说的OG（元老）。我们还有一个substack以及节目描述下方正在进行中的许许多多其他事情。所以如果你想了解更多，就去那里吧。找到我们，做任何你想做的事。但直到下一次，希望你喜欢这期节目。给我一些关于你希望我接下来揭穿什么的想法。我很乐意为你效劳。注意安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。
The Literature Review shows that Maslow's need hierarchy theory of human motivation has received little, clear, or consistent support from the available research findings. Some of Maslow's propositions are totally rejected, whilst others receive mixed and questionable support at best, which is a crazy statement for a theory that has been taught in schools, and psychology labs and classrooms and offices for decades at this point. But there you go. It may not even be true. Now, in his defense, Maslow never promoted his theory to be a final truth on human flourishing. He was honestly just writing, speculating, he was interested in this and something stuck. But it's interesting to see how many of those original theories he had and
它们变黑了。这把我吓死了。邪恶，醒醒吧。我是那个看到克里瓦克和德皮波实施谋杀的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得无动于衷。我说我没有罪。我将把这个秘密带进坟墓。在iHeart Radio应用程序上收听《Bone Valley》中的《魔鬼采石场》。
original ideas that he did take from the Blackfoot Nation have been taken out of context now in the modern day. I still think it's a nice idea. I still think it does provide a promise or a path to how we could provide for people and how society should and can operate and how we should take care of others. But does it deserve its position as one of the most famous theories of psychology? I don't know. Let me know what you think down below. That's all I have for you. As I said, it's a bonus episode. I always do these bonus episodes and I end up speaking for like 30, 40 minutes, but that is not their intention. We're trying to keep these short and sweet. So let me know what your thoughts are. Let me know if you think there is a better theory out there, better than
Apple Podcasts，或在你获取播客的任何地方收听。快乐至关重要，它也同样难以捉摸，但现在有一个令人兴奋的新方法来开启你的旅程，走向更加充满喜悦的生活，Joy 101。这是一个由我——霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的直播聊天。打开你的免费iHeart Radio应用程序。
Maslow's. Let me know if you were surprised to learn anything in this episode or if you have further context or information about this that I may have missed. As I said, I actually didn't know a lot of this until a listener reached out to me a couple of years ago and corrected something that I'd said in an episode. And I'm very grateful for that because it sent me down this really interesting path and I got to learn so much. So if there's anything else you want to contribute, I would love to hear from you in the comment section below on Spotify or you can DM me if you're listening elsewhere on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Also a reminder, we are now on Netflix. If you want to watch full episodes of The Psychology of Your 20s, not this episode though, because our
Joy 101，立即收听。由CVS呈现的霍达·科特比主持的Joy 101。每个人都把我当作一名足球运动员，但在此之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情感共存，从我出生起就是这样。这不是一个普通的播客。
bonus episodes are just for people who listen to the audio podcast, the OGs, as I would say. We also have a substack and just so much else going along and going on, not going along, going on down in the episode description. So head there if you want to learn more. Find us, do anything really. But until next time, I hope you enjoyed the episode. Give me any ideas of what you want me to debunk next. I would love to do it for you. Be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes.
这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着意味着什么进行的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·托尔南德斯（Javier Tornandez），请在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learning to Be Human》。你的丈夫并非你想象的那样。你的身体也并非你所想的那样。
They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevecette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the bonework.
你的身份由一段秘密的历史塑造。我是丹妮·夏皮罗，这些只是我将在《家族秘密》第14季中探索的众多惊人故事中的几个。他有点把我推开说，让开。然后他走出了前门，跳上一辆车开走了，那是我最后一次见到他。
Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《家族秘密》第14季。每个家庭都有其秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直在过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那可不是一个无辜之人的眼神。每个人都在对我说谎，隐瞒他们是谁吗？我感到了如此深切的绝望。
Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Cotty is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast.
我觉得这是我必须做的事。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Deep Cover the Family Man》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子来发表评论。
Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez, and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHA Radio, Apple Podcast, or whatever. you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was.
这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、诚挚的。只有关于活着意味着什么的坦诚对话。我是哈维尔·托尔纳德斯，请在 iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何平台上收听《学习做人》。你的丈夫并不是你所想的那样。你的身体也不是你原以为的那样。
Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro, and these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets. He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door, and he jumped in a car and drove off, and that was the last time I saw him.
你的身份是由一段秘密历史塑造的。我是丹妮·夏皮罗，这些只是我将在《家庭秘密》第十四季中探讨的众多惊人故事中的几个。他有点把我推开，说，让开。然后他从前门出去，跳上一辆车开车走了，那是我最后一次见到他。
Listen to Season 14 of Family Secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation.
在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《家庭秘密》第十四季。每个家庭都有自己的秘密。但是，当你发现你的父亲一直在过着双重生活时，会发生什么？这可不是一个无辜之人的眼神。每个人都在对我的真实身份撒谎吗？我感到如此绝望。
I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我觉得这是我不得不做的事。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《卧底：好男人》。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。